wayne rooney former england captain
leaving court after spending a day
giving evidence at this multi-million
pound war of the wags this was the turn
of the habs the husbands and boyfriends
with jamie vardy also in court for the
first time supporting his wife
we now know this is how agatha christie
done it a fake instagram post on a
basement flood another on gender
selection images shown in court now made
public planted by colleen rooney and
entirely made up to work out whether
rebecca vardy's account was leaking
stories to the sun
when rooney made that now infamous post
the court heard how her husband wayne
was fast asleep
over in america where he was playing at
the time he said he had no knowledge of
his wife's investigation until he woke
up that day but he said he was not
surprised his wife believed the leads
came from rebecca vardy
at the euros in 2016 where vardy was
accused of sitting behind rooney to get
publicity wayne rooney says he'd been
pulled aside by the then england manager
roy hodgson and coach gary neville who
asked him as captain to speak to jamie
vardy it was awkward he told the court
they asked him to ask his wife to calm
down and not bring any issues off the
field that were unnecessary disputed by
jamie vardy's people who in a statement
outside of court said wayne is talking
nonsense
wayne rooney claims he knew almost
nothing of it all right up until today
telling the court me sitting in this
room this week is the first time i'm
hearing almost everything on this case
what a way to find out
rooney described the impact of the case
as traumatic i've watched my wife over
the past two two and a half years really
struggle with everything that's gone on
become a different mother a different
wife
more and more people have become
embroiled in this case with every twist
and turn even the husbands and
boyfriends conceding they'd really
rather stay out of it katie spencer sky
news